1 attention luc ferrandez bonsoir pour
voir l'état des routes
est ce que c'est en fait c'est tout
simple que ce que des gens nous le
décrivent dans le reportage on n'a pas
mis assez d'argent point à la ligne
l'udc on en a promis à ses pieds on en
mettra pas plus que ce soit une équipe
pour que ce soit une équipe où que ce
soit l'autre parce que pour faire des
travaux en profondeur c'est à dire
égouts aqueduc surface gravier dans le
béton asphalte couvrir la rue c'est long
et c'est cher donc si on veut juste
faire refaire surface à son bus couvrir
des joints sont peut en faire plus mais
ça dure combien de temps
non non pas du tout mais c'est lorsqu'on
essaie de faire la poétique clio risée
c'est renoncer à août should ont fait
des pas la priorité de l'administration
si la priorité c'est les rues comme on
le fait nous à l'époque pendant
plusieurs années
l'arrondissement choisi ses priorités il
y aura un budget qui ont dit ok on en
met 25 % dans la chaussée cette année on
a mis 10 % dans les parcs on est capable
variés mais il faut avoir un plein il
faut avoir un plan pour juste sur un
même plan sur 10 ans avec les rues verte
les rues jaune et rouge qui à chaque
année on en choisit dans l'industrie on
en fait un peu on patch les autres où on
est capable de faire je vous dis pas
plus mais l'inter par exemple je vous
donne un exemple le budget du plateau
mont royal si on prenait si on mettait
dans le resurfaçage ça nous permettait
par 1.5 1.6 km par année sur 400 km
d'alger dans la ville de vire et par
extension me saint michel le territoire
est tellement grand que une proportion
de travaux qu'on peut faire sur une
année par rapport au nombre de
kilomètres de routes encore plus petit
donc c'est risible c'est risible mais
mon frère on les laisse se dégrader non
mais il ya plusieurs problèmes le
problème est générée par le poids des
camions d'abord les poteaux véhicules de
propre véhicule de la ville les
nouvelles souffleuse avec des grosses
grosses têtes qui peuvent manger se pose
ainsi pieds de neige d'un coup les
camions de transport de neige et les
autobus articulés sont tous les trois en
dehors en haut de la capacité de
portance de la rue et apprécier tous les
autres véhicules de livraison qui sont
de plus en plus gros de plus en plus
gros et de plus en plus lourd à vie ce
qu'on disait la semaine dernière
de réglementation sur les camions en
ville ma question il ya quand même une
logique les camions de déneigement avec
les souffleuses on sortira pas nous au
pl il va falloir qu'on les enlève parce
que les gens monchy reliques si on
ramasse quoi l'adage rapine la cie les
trottoirs sont bi ça non il faut qu'on
soit capable jauger entre les deux vont
sortir au point d'en nommer une rue pour
les conduites
en cuir pack humain un plan appelant
puis qu'on les change ça serait
peut-être bien de faire le surfaçage la
rue aussi le ferrandez en même temps
oui mais ça dépend c'est ça dépasse si
on le change dans le sens de la longueur
de la vue et à ce moment là oui les
refait le resurfaçage ou en fait juste
des puits pour accéder à chaque maison
est le nom il n'est pas fait le
resurfaçage de là avec moi je vous le
confirme le préfet ok revenus de valérie
planty réglée elle ne tenait salaires de
mai reste que ceux des revenus de jeu de
loyer et denis coderre dit attendez moi
je vais vous donner tous mes clients ne
donner un certain non mais je ne veux
pas vous donner tous les détails de mes
contrats privés qu'en pensez-vous l'udc
est pas c'est pas acceptable on veut
savoir si le parler de baseball on veut
savoir s'il a parlé de la taille des
immeubles on veut savoir s'il a parlé
avec evenko pour les événements les
sainte hélène qui sont les personnes qui
ont donné mandat à quels étaient les
mandats il a travaillé pour sting racing
reste une entreprise qui vend des
services musicaux il faisait pas des
chats religieux la raison pour laquelle
y est là c'est parce que ces boyaux qui
est à la tête de série et que monsieur
boyer coûts étaient des hommes baraqués
supporte le baseball alors qu'elles
étaient ces modes année ben là dessus je
suis partagé parce que monsieur coderre
en 2013 lorsqu'il s'est présenté comme
citoyen présenter à la mairie l'avait
commencé cette tradition de dire on va
déposer nos états financiers
il avait fait parce qu'il y avait des
candidats qui veulent un peu partout et
la raison pour laquelle il avait fait
puis vous regarde reste encore documenté
c'était de dire il faut que les citoyens
à notre confiance il faut que ce soit
transparent moi ce que je m'explique mal
c'est qu'aujourd'hui si on veut encore
avoir la confiance et la transparence de
ses propres mots il faut qu'ils puissent
le faire la loi l'y oblige son est très
clair mais cependant la tradition dû
déposer vos rapports d'impôts pour ce
qui est de la liste de ses clients et
attendront qui dépend son rapport
d'impôt la moindre des choses c'est
qu'ils le fassent et la pluie en moyens
à j + tedjar et d'accords qui ne donne
pas tous les détails de tous les
contrats qu'il a eu avec tous les
organismes mais qui pensent qu'ils
dépenseront rapport d'impôt c'est là
dessus qu'on veut la voir mais qu'il
dépose qu'ils arrêtent de débloquer les
plus justes
il dit qu'il était payé le double du
salaire du maire de serre à d'immenses
autour de 200 milles dans leur ai dit
qu'ils étaient payés le double environ
400 mille dollars on l'a pas payé 400
mille dollars pour ses dons de rédaction
là il va dire que lieu il ya quelque
chose il ya une raison pour laquelle on
le pays et est-ce que ça a un rapport
avec la vie municipale
rapidement les gens vont suivre la coop
26 puis je commençais l'émission avec ça
compte tenu de l'importance de l'enjeu
puis bon il ya des choses pas vrai qu'on
fait rien dans ses conférences là mais
au niveau des villes est ce qu'il ya des
leviers on parle de planter des arbres
quels sont les leviers qui peuvent
changer pour un maire une mairesse lui
qu il faut planter des arbres proches de
la pollution on s'est rendu compte que
les orques sont très des vents dominants
et qui absorbe la pollution de la rue
absorbe beaucoup de pollution au milieu
de la forêt en absorbe plus donc il faut
planter en ville il faut planter là où
il ya beaucoup de trafic et ça c'est
très difficile annie barrows aborde la
métropole ternois à l'époque on en avait
planté et ça a pris du temps parce que
évidemment c'est un lieu qui est assez
difficile les armes ont survécu et ça
fonctionne moi je pense que localement
dans chacun des arrondissements y des
îlots de chaleur commençons par ça pour
gilles changer la planète jour au
lendemain commençant par des choses qui
sont réalisables précisant les petits
gestes les îlots de chaleur planter des
arbres sur les trottoirs roulants ne pas
essayer d'en verte de verdir un peu
comme le dépôt dans les rues l'offre on
peut pas mettre de de planter des arbres
on est capable de faire autrement et je
pense que les arrondissements doivent le
faire à petite échelle alors un sujet
que vous faire réagir je suis sûr
discours de michael rousseau grands
patrons pdg d'air canada qui vient à
montréal mercredi
la chambre de commerce du grand montréal
et qu'ils ont on annonce déjà qu'il ne
prononcerait pas un mot de français
on le confirme aujourd'hui par son
bureau
air canada je le rappelle aux gens son
siège social par la loi c'est à montréal
luc ferrandez comment je vais réagir je
comprends pas que la chambre de commerce
mais tiennent l'invitation que monsieur
rousseau parle à ses actionnaires dans
une assemblée d'actionnaires de robert
canada en anglais seulement bcr canada
ce sont des actionnaires ça va si on
choisit des actionnaires la compagnie
mais toutes les interventions de la
quête de la chambre de commerce vise à
dire que montréal est une ville arrivée
qu un visage francophone esquisse
hilarante distincte du reste de
l'amérique ont fait une publicité
monstre le tue pour attirer notamment
des investisseurs on parle toujours de
la dualité français anglais l'europe en
amérique du nord etc et quand il tonne m
si ses bottes qui de dire à quelqu'un
ben non tu peux pas venir ici parler
juste en anglais mais ne le font pas
annie mais les babines suivent pas les
boîtes in dans ce col on est quand même
c'est quand même le siège social ici à
montréal montréal est la première ville
francophone en amérique du nord on
n'arrête pas de s'inventer on parle de
défendre le français et le président
d'air canada qui s'appelle rousseau donc
écrit en québécois en france elle sait
pas où sont ces rousseau qui est pas
capable venez nous faire un discours en
français qui auraient pu bilingue il
aurait pu parler un peu en français à
toulon est et reste à maureilhan depuis
2006 il doit comprendre les français oui
enfin ça c'est désolant tout en français
ça aurait été impossible il parle pas
français mais que rien aucun goût de
français ça fait sursauter beaucoup de
gens beaucoup plus qu'on accepte ce ici
par la chambre de commerce le aussi je
suis déçu parce que c'est ajouter
quelque chose bien sûr les gens
d'affaires c'est pas les gens d'affaires
sont aussi devenus des francophones
c'est à dire que 80% des gens d'affaires
à montréal sont francophones donc
c'est pas comme s'ils disaient mais moi
j'ai pas parlé à la population s'étend
jusqu'aux champs d'achat les gens
d'affaires aussi veulent vous entendre
en français alors pourquoi la chambre de
commerce impose à ses clients
la question est lancée en terminant
avant de vous laisser aller
combien il y avait pourtant le vote par
anticipation
douze pour sa touche 9 12 29 on n'a pas
de comparer le comparable parce qu'il
n'y avait pas deux jours avant mais une
simple c'est pau pierce à 12,9 première
fin de semaine année mais c'est sur deux
jours c'est ça la question on saura
demain parce que les troupes sont en
train de valider qui est allé voter vont
ils ont reçu la liste ils si demain on
sera les quelques petites d'électeurs et
en sortie pour aller voter et on va
pouvoir savoir de quel parti quel parti
en avance pour mais effectivement c'est
sur deux jours donc c'est difficile de
dire c'était 6% la dernière fois lors le
fait deux fois fait que ça fait douze
pour ça c'est un peu difficile
aujourd'hui de pouvoir il y en a qui est
en avance poule oui mais si le passé est
garant du présent code colère toujours
été fort sur le vote d'anticipation de
toujours pour projet montréal a toujours
perdu le vote d'anticipation jamais tous
dans vos
quand vos proches l'avouent demande mais
toi tu connais sol qui va gagner vous
dire quoi dieu qui a ni le moi je
mettais ma prédiction 5% davantage pour
rallier plan auquel j'ai de plus en plus
chalet est aujourd'hui la vanille à
faire monter tant au cou la semaine
passée ça mais je les récupère abc le
jeu leur sort parce que à cause de vote
de ballard bowl
d'après-vous
12% actuellement les sondages pas
certain que les 12% avant d'aller voter
c'est ça la grosse ex enlève à côté moi
c'est la semaine des locaux tôt c'est la
dernière semaine de la campagne c'est là
que tout sort un petit rat shop sourire
tout croche c'est là que ça peut ça peut
balancer d'un côté ou de l'autre
cependant ceux qui sont déjà sur un
autre ton et changera pas ce sont les
sucs sont indécis qui reste à se faire
convaincant et là avec monsieur coderre
madame valérie plan il va bien voir que
les deux soient séduisant gardez vos
oreillette parce qu'après on va faire
une michelle robidoux quatrième
charlebois avec ferland avec les tigres
avec troènes qui est décédé un grand
grand grand musicien guitariste qui nous
a quittés merci à vous deux talus bercé
revoir